[Music]
[Music]
we got some cringe whiskey oh yeah let's
watch this we got 10 minutes left let's
do it
all right are we really going to dunk on
this dude i've
i've had a reasonably successful week at
work
pause it and dude this guy is so crazy
dude
oh what an idiot you got a t-shirt that
says dick on it whoa
so cringe dude i'm cringing is this guy
bald oh he's bald look at how dirty his
place is oh cringe man
this guy goes to work
cringe dude dude he's got boxes
everywhere cringe
this friday morning i'm relaxing myrtle
you can see that things are in a little
bit of disarray back there
oh wait i've seen this
oh i think his wife like
walks out on him in the middle of this
video and he keeps it he keeps reviewing
the whiskey keep going
oh he just
well cindy and i are breaking up
she's moving out
and
the way i can enjoy that i see a lot no
it's hard no it's really [ __ ] hard
but i'm gonna have some uh
some laphroaig 10
laphroaig 10 has been my you know he
said that [ __ ] and this video went viral
every like whiskey like every agency
that markets for whiskey
is just like watching this video like
what does he pull out what does he pull
out what does he play yeah yeah
laphroaig 10 they're like oh
oh i thought he was going to pull out
the makers man jesus [ __ ]
go to single malt
and then pause it and then lefreg is
like no we can work with it
hold on what if we spin it yeah what if
we spin it
help john out the [ __ ] huh
huh
huh years now
especially when it comes to
peated malts
and uh i like you know what i hate about
the word malt is it makes it sound like
it seems like a milkshake yeah you drink
that [ __ ] and you're like this tastes
like horse foot cleaner stuff because
it's just
no compromises
just give me the smoke give me the peep
oh
wait run that [ __ ] again
that was a hard
ass pop
what a video for international women's
day i know
i know oh yeah
empowerment
you know yeah man get that swirling
even my sniffer is out of whack so i
mean if you're just listening
his wife is just fully packing up in the
background
and he's like in the midst of a whiskey
review
hasn't even taken a sip yet he's just
airing it out
i think i know why she's leaving
why
she can't [ __ ] handle alpha like this
all right
why wouldn't you wait why wouldn't you
wait like
20 minutes until she's gone an hour
or an hour
does it have to be now yeah
you know here it comes here it comes
gotta coat that glass
now he's there's a bit to the floor
road tar
he's road tar smoke
and he's packing up and he's just
sniffing the glass and telling us what
the ingredients are yeah and more roads
are
he's thinking about all the whiskey's
gonna get the drink now she's gone
[Music]
he's getting ready to go to monster jam
oh yeah
for road tar it's really smooth
it's got that medicinal quality to it
why
it's got that medicine
just [ __ ] 30 years of marriage
30 years of marriage bye
bye
that's how it ends shut up i'm filming
bye shh
how reactionary was that [ __ ] dude yeah
it startled him then he just said bye
bye
get out
nice little quality to it do it again
bye
it's got that
medicinal quality to it
bye
it's got that medicine bye peace
bye deuces yeah what if he just threw a
hand up didn't even
yeah and just like a little medicinal
quality
but yeah this medicinal quality yeah
additional quality what have you said
just a little stutter
anyways as i was saying medicinal
quality it's pissed that he lost his
train of thought by
the [ __ ] was it
this sorry medicinal quality to it
she slams the door he opens it back up
what the [ __ ] is your problem this
little quality to it
it's almost like
there's a honey note to it compared to
the kalila that i was drinking earlier
does she
yeah she left it open drinking earlier
too so this is like my man is a couple
glasses in at this point
yeah
yeah you know
this is very nice
well yeah add a little water
this vodka i've also been watching the
movie vanishing point
that's good and i'm gonna get into some
more of those uh
early 70s hot rod kind of movies hell
yeah watching those
now that my wife's gonna relive my youth
a little bit
i remember that one uh from i think i
haven't watched it in 40 years and i'm
watching it this morning
there's gonna be a few others you know
like white line fever and
i can't look away yeah me either
i'm sorry why is this so like
mesmerizing
captivated movies like that
from the early 70s
and high-powered cars and things like
that and he he uploaded this [ __ ] man
craig yeah freud i've i've liked freud
since the first time i tried it wait
let's hit that yeah
i run that smell back one time and that
groan
yeah freud i
liked freud since the first time i tried
it's pete it's smoke
it's some brian oh she's gotta come back
some dirty socks i'm sorry if you're
listening on audio this is
bro this is
yeah this is like performance art dude
yeah it's amazing looking yoko ono
wishes she could do something this great
yeah
um
yeah
i highly recommend this
cheers slanjovar
yeah what's when was his last upload man
let's let's have a look yeah let's see
how he's doing
damn that lg was hard that outro was
actually some food
[ __ ] food quick swim stuff
absolutely
what is that from
um
starcraft oh no what is that from
when was his last one he uploaded a day
ago oh let's let's see it let's hit
it how's he doing
food quake
food quick we don't [ __ ] around with
women here at food quick
we are all alone food quake boys only
well just boy because it's one man in
this house
this is so funny it's like
he's like celebrating this [ __ ] just
bottles of ethanol yeah like yeah my
life is [ __ ] good
in terms of the camera it's just drunk
as [ __ ]
i picture this it's so bumpy
i picture there's like some [ __ ]
1850s [ __ ] we're just like weird like
circled cars and yeah just like
decrepits you know burn stain bottles
like yeah we got all the elixirs here
man
[Laughter]
a jar full of calm what's up what's up
what punching his own boss
oh okay
i have tonight
an interesting whiskey oh he's on green
screen seems like he's
wait is that all of his bottles
bro that [ __ ] i thought was is that real
yo dude hell yeah that's some
that's some dude interior design right
yeah
his wife moved out he's like finally
i think we know why she left
she couldn't handle this babe i want to
start a whiskey wall yeah what no
come on
which i bought online
from alberta
but i
let's go
i could have probably got it just a bit
cheaper had i waited
for the premium spirits release like
three days later but i saw it advertised
this guy's so canadian yeah
on line and it was so easy to just click
on it so i clicked on it
this one here is a 22 year old
pike creek
dude i for one s half second i thought
that was a bottle of hennessy
this is like
just do say just yeah i'm going in right
now
i'm going to the club right now
canadian whiskey finished in px sherry
casks
750 mils 45
yeah dude good good
good
750 mils
good good yeah my wife is the [ __ ] in
this situation
yeah
my wife is the problem we're gonna be
slamming this whole thing today yeah
what
dude he just does that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
those guys do yeah yeah
a little throat clearer
damn bro and then he then he's like well
then
he's like time for the next part of the
video just walks right into a car
[Laughter]
or just like gets in his car and starts
it up like hey what the [ __ ]
and like i said 22 years old
i have had
well first of all let me pour
a dram of this and then i'll talk about
it
talk about
talking about experiences with pike
creek in the past
okay
damn that [ __ ] is sad man
yeah dude since my wife left these are
all the bottles of liquor i was able to
complete yeah
you have a problem man
[Laughter]
how many views
i mean you know whatever do you
maybe he doesn't finish the bottles you
know maybe he donates them this is the
riddler in 30 years
yeah
so after batman broke my back
and i got out of the psych ward
i started drinking because i couldn't
get health care and you know but i still
really wanted to make content
i always used to like streaming so you
know back in the day though
but you know gotham's uh healthcare plan
is really uh it's not welcoming to those
born in 1970s so
uh he broke my back i tried suing him
but you know the wayne foundation
they're just too powerful so
what else am i gonna do
and you know i saw the ad for this this
whiskey here this is an alberta rye
whiskey it's uh pike creek i believe
breaks through the walls 20 yeah what i
tell your [ __ ] ass about
drinking i [ __ ] your wife
[Laughter]
i thought i broke your back 30 years ago
this is crabs in my shoulders it's my
whiskey wall
batman no
no my whiskey wall what the [ __ ] are you
doing
just tearing through in his [ __ ]
super suit yeah my suit makes me 30
years younger it's like i'm 25 again
no no stop riddle me this [ __ ] face can
you still walk
batarang through his kneecaps
oh my god
my god
[Laughter]
oh my [ __ ] god
dude in the movie he does like this like
[ __ ] like narcon
what is it in the
movie batman batman gets all [ __ ] up
he does like a narcon shot okay to like
give him adrenaline again he starts
[ __ ] destroying this guy's face it's
just killing me the idea of like batman
when all when they're all older he just
has access to like crazy steroids and
[ __ ] so he's just still young [ __ ]
and they're like come on man it's over
dude
come on
just just
leave my whiskey
yeah
just trying to [ __ ] you up all over
again
joker just has like 10 years he comes
back and does this again
joker's dementia in like a [ __ ]
mental like impatient situation like he
doesn't even know who he is
mr wayne remember me
mr wayne
he doesn't remember anything
get the [ __ ] out of my way
just
just take some of the wheelchair and
just runs him up to the top of a
mountain
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my god do you remember me
no no
is this a joke yeah
no yeah
i don't
i don't
maybe you will now
just punches him in the [ __ ] head
oh my god
two faces 90 like on his deathbed just
like hooked up to him she's like
the whole family's like around
well you know he wasn't a great person
but he tried his best and this is in the
corner yeah he didn't try hard enough
unplugging it
plugs all this [ __ ]
just starts punching his dead ass body
it's like full mount just
oh my god